i want to know i hear constantly
consist consistently might be a better
word since we're focusing on words i
hear consistently
from women that they don't feel they're
getting
recognition for the work they've done
and i'm
constantly hearing from men
how much they've done and how much they
deserve
a promotion and raise it's like
incessant
men are like literally non-stop coming
at me with
you know their their high fives um
and women sometimes i hear from them
that they don't feel they got credit
you have strategies around this is this
a a trend that you hear about a lot in
your research
i mean this is sort of that i work twice
as hard for half the rewards kind of
thing
true phenomena and yeah i mean yeah
there's there is truth behind that yeah
um
but in that truth is also what are you
going to do about that
right it is it is what it is to some
extent
and so you know what i talk about in the
second half of the book
is i actually started from the back
did you you yeah right
so you really liked chapter 13. what i
do is i always start with the last two
chapters my strategy for guests and show
i listen i start with the last two
chapters
yeah because i feel like they summarize
what they've said in the book
then i go back and read listen to the
entire book huh interesting see that i
get to
hear the end twice that's some good
bsing jason
actually if you actually if you ever
want to do it on a book you will your
retention will go way out all right
because you've listened to the summary
twice
yeah at the beginning and the end okay
and good authors will a lot of times
sort of
tell you upfront hey here's what we're
going to do in the book yeah but there's
nothing like that summary
okay so the summary that you sort of
read which you are so yeah that you
listen to
um you know i talk about how a lot of i
mean it's it's this
we we are jaded and bitter in lots of
ways because
when our hard work doesn't speak for
itself or when we put in the effort and
the rewards go to somebody else or that
we keep or we keep hitting the same
walls over and over and over again
we become jaded and bitter or you know
there's people who have wronged us
or and we hold on to that it's like a
chip on our shoulder i ask my students
sometimes
think about a time when somebody wronged
you or some situation that still has you
feeling angry i mean within 10 seconds
people can recall two or three instances
really
you can too come on not too many i'll
kind of let them go but i'm older in my
career
yeah and because you've read the last
chapter of my book um
and so yeah so i talk about you know how
a lot of times we things become we let
it make us bitter
and instead of it whenever something is
starting to make us bitter we need to be
asking ourselves how does this make us
better
not bitter got it and so when we think
about making ourselves better and not
bitter how
then we understand that sort of negative
that failure
that those those drawdowns and what is
it that we value why does it still
bother us why is it
still a chip on our shoulder what's the
one you can tell me without telling the
names and
protecting the innocent but you're in
academia so the stakes are so low that
you must have had people
try to screw you over many times yeah i
know i really will get canceled when i
start talking about the times i've been
screwed over in academia
no you know loyalty is so loyalty is so
big to me like that's like me too one of
them my number one it's probably yeah
like i feel like hard work and loyalty
on my tomb well hard work should come
forth after enriching delighting and
guiding now that you know that but
no i mean loyalty and trustworthiness
and sort of empathy like those are my
three
i feel like you switch out any one of
those and you become like a completely
different
sort of person and i mean i think the
times it's still sort of
it's it's those situations where um
you know someone stabs you in the back
and you're like
and especially when you value loyalty
and
trustworthiness and you and you really
like
have somebody's best interests at heart
and then you realize that other people
are those who
for just a tiny bit of personal gain
will step on lots of other people
yeah so i think it's those and i think
this is not unique to me i think we all
sort of have
these experiences where we feel that
this has happened but
you have to make it how does this make
you better and not bitter how do you
change that
how do you and i mean i think it's you
didn't tell me yours by the way a nice
deflect
i asked you yours i gave you the i gave
you the macros you didn't give me your
example but there's one i can see it in
your eyes
there's one there's actually two but
yeah well make a composite
yeah compositive for me that person's
not gonna listen to this they're
they're a narcissist the last thing
they're going to do is this true they
are take the time to listen to you and
your success now yeah no they are a
narcissist because the you know anyways
um but go ahead tell us what happened
and then tell us how i feel like i'm
like on
i feel like i'm on like the ellen show
or something
i don't want you to cry ellen is trying
to secretly reveal like the gender of my
i'm not pregnant but i'm feeling
revealed the gender reveal of my my baby
so i've always dreamed of like being in
a situation when somebody tries to like
get information out of me on like a talk
show
so this kind of feels like this is it so
tell us the composite of how you got
this person and the narcissist who uh
screwed you and then how you let it not
make you better
well i think the i'll start with the
second piece first and then we'll ease
our way into the
i think the um you know the not letting
it i mean there's it's entrepreneurs
doing this all the time as well right
you have to sort of ride the emotions
while understanding those emotions but
not getting carried away by that so what
i mean by like entrepreneurs sometimes
you know you have these extreme highs
and these extreme lows
and often they're all in the same day
and you have to be able to i think one
of the characteristics that makes a
really good founder is being able to
understand that there's going to be huge
failures and huge successes and huge
really depressing days and really
exhilarating days
and while you're understanding that
still being able to feel those emotions
while not getting carried away with it
consumed by them
yeah you don't want to be consumed by
them but you want to understand them
because there's so much
data in those emotions there's so much
data in
why does it feel so depressing why
is it like what is it that's really
nagging at me and understanding that
sort of
feeling and i think unpacking it
unpacking sitting with it
meditating on it and knowing what i talk
about a lot which is
life rhymes and we have situations in
our life that have made us
feel a certain way yes and then a couple
years later
we'll we'll it'll be a different context
or a different situation
but will feel that same emotion or that
same feeling like something won't sit
right
and there's so much information in that
that's how we build our experience and
our mental models and our schemas and
our intuition
that's how we sort of hone it by being
able to give us yours because then i'll
give you mine
you give me can you give me yours first
and then i'll give you mine i'm trying
to get you to answer a question here i'm
the host and then you're you're
constantly throwing
you said you're gonna give me your yours
too so well i was gonna give it to you
as a reward for giving me yours first
i need a little sweetener all right okay
fine i'll give it to you
well uh yeah so speaking of edge
i have always looked at
when you are screwed when people do come
at you and they do in business
yes uh and i i long looked at business
as war
yeah um and there's really two types of
confrontations when it comes to violence
there's quick and there's extended right
yeah and if you look at the samurai and
that's why to
mufune is on the wall over there and
or the jedi which are modeled after
samurai um
when they take that sword out and they
use it and if you ever see yojimbo
there's a famous scene which
takes the sword out and he cuts a guy's
arm off and it lays on the floor
and then they cut to the sword being put
back on his belt and into the sheath and
the blood being taken off of it
and it happens in seconds and then it's
over
as opposed to a bar room brawl which
goes on forever
or a war yeah that goes on forever and i
think in my younger years sometimes i
went to war with people and it was never
ending
because it was not definitive and what
i've learned over time is you
you know i went to war with people over
decades or a decade
now if i have to go to war with somebody
it's going to be either
they're ignored and they're just ghosted
forever
and i just give them zero attention
or the possibility is like the cantina
scene in the original star wars where
obi-wan takes out and he says listen
this young one is not worth your trouble
the guy says well you know i want to
fight anyway and it takes out the sword
and cuts the guy's arm off if you
remember that scene
lucas took that from kurosawa and then
that's why kurosawa's books on the wall
here that's one of my heroes
um and by the way that is a great book
something like a autobiography
um he stole that lucas from kurosawa
from the yojimbo scene
and you see the guy's arm fall on the
ground yeah and then the lightsabers put
away and turned off
just like the sword went away and it's
turned off and so now when somebody does
something discriminated happened
recently
i just swung the sword cut their arm off
put it away and never show that person's
name or
that person will never be in our my life
again
never will i take the sword out again
because i cut their arm off already i
don't they already learned their lesson
but not every one has that opportunity
to somebody else
you must just you have to train with the
sword just train
sounds almost like a count of monte
cristo sort of thing like you train and
you train you train and then like
pow there's like didn't he stay in the
jail for a long extended period of time
and then got his revenge
but he did his rev like he
because it's a shallow victory
afterwards like trust me
in your gymbo or prevents that other
person from
like retaliating they have one arm and
they want to keep it
i mean i know it's about speaking in
generalities you're giving like
you're talking about if somebody comes
at you yeah
and you show them that sword yeah and
they experience
what it feels like for that blade to hit
they very rarely would say
you know what i'd like to be in front of
that blade again
and in this case it was just dropping
the top legal firm in the world
and a bunch of paper on somebody and
saying pink
yeah but see this is this is the thing
about i mean
not everyone this is i mean frivolous
lawsuits are everywhere
this is not frivolous okay but this is a
letter
here's what's gonna happen yeah well
this is the thing i mean
we the the the legal system is supposed
to
be about justice and about truth and
about all these sorts of things
do you believe that it is um i believe
it's flawed but the best one we got
you know so far in humanity um but
and and it can work for the underdog
more than the person who is
the person with the big uh chip stack
but it could also work the other way and
so i was recently advising somebody who
got screwed
and didn't have a lot of power yeah it
is a good is a valid observation you're
making which is
i have resources now and i have the
sword yeah but when i didn't
somebody else was in a similar situation
i said you know what you should do
you should write a blog post and you
should detail exactly how this investor
screwed you
i said and then you should say to them
as they've ousted you from your company
um i uh i disagree with what you've done
and i'm not going to sue you but i'm
going to write this blog post
and i'm going to publish it and i'm
gonna
give the story to the wall street
journal and business insider and anybody
else will listen
and i'm going to tell every founder
who contact i'm going to put your name
in the title and every founder
i'm going to put in the first sentence
email me anytime if you would like a
reference for
this individual right i said and then
watch exactly how quickly and that's a
different type of story and then that
investor sues you for slander
no no no why not
because the investor knows that
suing a founder is the worst
possible recourse and settling with the
founder
is the best possible recourse because
then they go you're crazy
and you don't care and let me tell you
something there is one person
you do not want to fight with which is
somebody who has nothing left to lose
and that's the there's see this is where
having nothing left to lose is a
very powerful thing when you truly get
screwed and you're you've got nothing
yeah
then the other person has to realize
well you're backed into a corner so you
might as well fight your way out
there's a chance you might make it out
and the person then who has a lot at
stake who has the money and the power
says do i want to risk everything i've
spent 50 years building
to have this blog post on the internet
and that person i'm going to sue them
and they have nothing and then they're
just going to write more blog posts
yeah it's so complicated you
underestimate the power of
i just think there's so much there's so
much nuance there right there's
the nuance behind the the person with
the resources who can continue right
whereas the other person can't continue
because they don't have the resources
for the
for the um you know for the lawyers and
the legal
you you underestimate that person who
can then write
his or her own blog post even if it's
complete lies all of these sorts of
things i mean
i think the the vc would never do that
because once they're faced with the
possibility of
other founders seeing them mixing it up
with a founder and not being able to
control that relationship they will just
say it's not worth
dealing with that person this actually
happened online just over the last
couple days with the vc who's
been tweeting crazy stuff um and every a
couple people have bad stories about
this person i won't say their name on
the show but
um just makes it very hard for that
investor then
when they're having a conversation with
a founder
to say i'm not going to
create radioactivity around your startup
yeah right it's the last thing you want
tell us your story
we're going to talk about i mean there's
so many hints of what you said already
i mean obviously when i feel like the
bitterness comes when
there's legal sort of things and i mean
but
but that is i'm going to get some of
your advice offline about yeah without
these sort of well here's the thing
about bitterness
yeah a lot of times if people feel
there's no off ramp you know like they
said with the uh iran situation give
them an offer
yeah if people feel powerless yeah they
will try to take their power back
and that could be very dangerous for you
so that's why like the art of saddling
yeah that's why it's kind of nice when
you take the sword out and you're like
here's a sword
and i'm about to swing it and then
they're like oh
no you put this right away okay great or
you swing it and it's like you still got
one assuming that that other person is a
rational logical person but anyways
you know